[ Music plays indistinctly
on stereo ]
Aah!
Oh! Aah!
[ Children scream ]
[ Audience groans ]
You're a "Fortnite" kid now.
[ Laughter ]
The biggest threat to suburban
white teens in this country
is opioids.
Close second?
Trampolines.
[ Audience groans ]
Maybe someone just dared him
to rim himself.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
I admire him for going for it.
[ Springs creak ]
-No!
-Oh, my --
[ Audience groans ]
Well, you bitch-ass parents
aren't gonna like
to hear this,
but I think
he would have been fine
if the net wasn't there.
I've invented the safest way
to enjoy
the deadly double bounce.
You can do it anywhere,
except on a trampoline.
The only other requirement
is that you respect
the Double BC
by saying "boing."
[ Laughter ]
Double BC!
Both: Boing!
Tosh: Double BC!
Boing!
Double BC!
-So, how's everything ta--
-Double BC!
Boing!
[ Laughter ]
Tosh: Double BC!
Boing!
Hey, I'm --
Double BC!
Boing!
[ Laughter ]
Ugh. [ Laughs ]
Nasty.
Double BC!
Together: Boing!
Boing.
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep]
Double BC!
Boing!
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
Double BC!
Audience: Boing!
Not since surprise trust falls
have I created
such a pointless sensation.
Post your own Double BC vids,
and we'll send you
upwards of $100.
Upwards, but most likely zero.